vous êtes ancien comptable oui retraitée
à 1275 euros tout à fait bien entendu
vous vous en sortez pas vous avez dit je
préfère me suicider plutôt que de
demander un euro à ma fille ah mais non
à tous mes enfants nous en a qu'une vie
j'en ai trois enfants et voulaient pour
rien leur nom
j'ai élevé tout simple mais en forme
série 1
j'en ai bavé des ronds de chapeau parce
que la politique de l' enveloppe je la
connais c'est à dire dawa tâche au
surtemps pour le pdf temps pour les
cantines
j'ai payé ma maison rarement en faisant
des crêpes en faisant si en faisant ça
bien sûr j'ai un toit sur la tête bien
sûr j'ai une maison qui propre et soigné
parce que je fais tout moi-même mais
mais mais est ce que j'ai le droit de je
veux au travail et parce que je ne veux
pas demander quoi que ce soit mes
enfants en plus j'ai mes petits enfants
leur maman elle a des problèmes d'emploi
je me paie tellement de soucis pour eux
et en plus il faut savoir aussi que
j'habite les territoires oubliés
c'est à dire j'habite à 12 km de
bergerac il faut une voiture pour aller
chercher même en les 8 ou un diable
vauvert si j'ose dire et je ne peux pas
rester autrement avec l'essence qui a
augmenté tout moi mon rêve ce n'est pas
de prendre aux riches etc
c'est d'aller au centre leclerc
pardonnez-moi remplir le chariot
sauvegarder ce que je veux c'est ça il
est produit de première nécessité de
voilà donc à entendre la tuberie oui
alors je souhaiterais avoir un petit
emploi qui me rapporte par exemple 300
ou 400 euros par mois qui me permettent
bien sûr accompagné mes petits enfants
de pouvoir être plus tranquille et ne
plus demander quoi que ce soit pour une
perche fait moins bien sûr bérézina
question monsieur le ministre je vais
apprendre concrètement là dessus
aujourd'hui dans le système de retraite
que vous connaissez si vous travaillez
vous n'avez pas droit et donc vous
n'avez pas d'euros supplémentaires
demain on pourra faire ce qu'on appelle
le cumul emploi-retraite avec le sait
proposer c'est écrit dans le rapport de
voix et c'est ce qu'on va appliquer
c'est à dire que vous avez aujourd'hui
1200 115 euros par mois vous prenez un
petit emploi qui fait 300 400 euros vous
allez acquérir des points
ces pauvres se transforme en un euro
donc vous aurez une pension plus élevée
à mesure que vous continuez à travailler
et c'est normal c'est comme ça qu'on
entend également pouvoir pour ceux qui
le veulent
on oblige évidemment personne n'a
travaillé non celle arrêtée
vous n'êtes quand vous êtes à la
retraite c'est quand vous êtes à la
retraite si jamais la vraie reine ont
fait cumuler avec son salaire le salaire
excusez moi le terme avec le solaire
bouna qui arrêtera de droite ont leur
vie à la retraite est gênante pour la
retraite ou non oui évidemment vous avez
du salaire de droite de l'avenue les
nanas qui aurait pas droit pour la
retraite gelé déjà fait je vous le
garantis alors sur facture bouna qui
reste rien dire ce que vous rendre sur
l'île jusqu'à très tard l'âge de
cotisation pour la retraite
ce qui veut dire qu'on permet à des
autres et de la guerre et des amis
retraités qu'à la tombe en fait pas
donné comme josiane des retraités
nous aurons tellement basses que les
jeunes travailleurs et à écouter ce que
dit joseph joseph deux ans j'ai écouté
juste que dit josiane j'ai dit je suis à
la retraite je trempe on peut échanger
traduisez comme ça non avant je n'aimais
retraite après geoffrey que josiane
seulement je veux laisser les seuls
ministres n'hésitent allez y continuez
de vous corriger ses troupes vous dites
je touche x
je veux mon idéal c'est travailler un
petit peu plus je vous dis dans le
nouveau système
si vous travaillez un petit peu plus
votre pension va augmenter c'est simple
ce que je dis aujourd'hui si vous
travaillez plus sereine je vais
travailler plus pour ne pas avoir
demandé d'argent à mes enfants
voilà accusé me répond à josiane sur le
système d mais moi ça aujourd'hui on
sait aujourd'hui si josiane serait
travail à 18 à 300 euros
elle n'aura pas de pension
supplémentaire demain elle travaille et
fait son petit bout la 300 euros en plus
sa retraite alors à une pression qui va
augmenter
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal
[Applaudissements]
il n'a pas terminé josé indéterminée la
principale intéressée de sable etc par
une seconde je n'ai pas terminé
aujourd'hui moi quand il ya eu la cg on
m'a pris 47 euros avec map nombreuses
tensions prend 47 euros je comprends on
nous dit on nous rembourse
vous savez combien m'a remboursé mois
7h11 alors que j'estime qu'on se moque
de moi que les élites en france qui ne
sont plus des élites d'ailleurs parce
que ce sont des énarques qui sont
complètement déconnectés de la réalité
est moins qui habite une région pauvre
parce qu'il faut en parler avec un
chômage record parce que je ne pense pas
qu'à moi dans ce que je pars bien sûr
comment je vais faire pour rentrer dans
un ehpad ou un vieux pad à 2500 euros
par mois parce qu'il faut que j'y pense
maintenant puisque je vais avoir 70
euros dans 15 heures sur l'a 10 ans dans
15 jours
non mais là à la raison josiane ce
qu'elle dit elle elle représente plein
de français qui nous regardent pour ça
on a pris vraiment des français
représentatifs parce que y en a des
milliers qui sont dans le cadre de
josiane et c'est vrai que voilà je
vienne à la mise 275 euros par mois et
on paie jose 1 elle veut travailler à
niveau là moi je veux bien travailler
pour gagner 300 400 euros le pal veut
parce qu'elle est obligée l'achat mais
qu'elle donnera président je fais du
bénévolat je m'occuperai d'une
association s'occupe déjà de maîtrise en
forme pour faire le rugby et mais je
viens je leur dis aux jeunes juste avant
10 rennes samedi elle pourrait pas aller
travailler à la ratp que garrido direct
quelques arrêts d'autres qui la paria
gars donc je me faire l'avocat du diable
mine de rien josiane c'est pas la faute
du gouvernement place jeune fille
josiane est à 1275 euros aujourd'hui il
ya eu avant il ya eu ben ali avant il ya
eu avant il ya eu des républiques à
problème c'est que l'argent tombe pas du
ciel enfin oui oui mais bon il ya un
moment je veux bien mais malheureusement
on peut tous être dans la démagogie et
dire qu'on va augmenter tous les
salaires est toutes les retraites
l'argent il faut trouver quelque part
mais vous avez raison madame d'argent
que le trouver quelques alors
politique vélo parce que je vais dire on
peut raconter toute la soirée combat
donné à tout le monde et bien sûr les
autres sur ton de le faire pour nous
sortir la fraude fiscale et je pense
qu'ils aient un but qui est fait plutôt
efficace par m mais il ya un moment
non mais je ne parle pas josiane mais de
manière générale on peut tout se dire
que c'est la faute des politiques de
tout ça mais non l'argent il ne tombe
pas du ciel raquel garrido
dites moi comment on financer une
retraite à 60 ans est ce si vous voulez
mais anastasie vous avez déjà donné des
éléments de réponse tout à leur sortie
les travers l'augmentation de salaire
pour la structure de quelque part
absolument alors que c'est les français
qui paient des impôts de france et la
caisse des retraites laurence ça y est
alors quel est votre solution en une
phrase de raquel garrido c'est vrai à
une phrase mais d'abord admettons que
nous sommes dans un pays très riche nous
ne sommes pas à payer du tiers monde
ah ouais fin fond de l'afrique nous
sommes par exemple un pays qui recordman
de millionnaire nous sommes un pays qui
est recorman en dividendes versés aux
actionnaires de l'oseille il y en a ici
d'accord et simplement on a un président
qui est le président des ultras riches
donc pour l'instant ce qu'il a fait
c'est prendre de l'argent proposé